a british doctor we've been telling you
about
has been pulled from the u.n commission
investigating the origins of covet
well there's no official reason for his
departure dr peter dasak
was a critic of the wuhan lab leak
theory said nothing
to that and face backlash for his ties
to the facility
he helped get the nih money into wuhan
gop senator marco rubio is pushing a
bill to sanction
china over the covet investigation and
he joins us now good morning to you
hey good morning guys good morning so
senator tell us about the
covet act well what it says is within 90
days of the bill passing if china hasn't
allowed for a full clear
transparent investigation as to how this
thing started we start sanctioning
people involved in the sciences over
there people involved in this research
the institutions involved in this
research
we cut off any and all federal funding
for any research that's
gain a function or anything like it in
conjunction with any of these
agencies over there look we already know
enough about what happened in china
i think to tell you they've done
something wrong which is they haven't
allowed the world to fully understand
how this thing began and they've covered
it up
now what it actually leads to that's
what the world needs to know because
the next one could be far worse than
this i mean chronovirus is terrible
covet has been
terrible it has killed people it's but
you've seen what it's done to our
society and our country and the world
the next one could be much deadlier much
more disruptive
we did people forget all this research
that china does
is still going on right now they're
doing as we speak they're doing it today
it doesn't stop this continues it does
not you know but
don't worry the white house is on the
case because if china does not go along
with another investigation
and be more forthcoming and start
spilling some beans
the white house is going to
internationally isolate them
well look i mean i think that there's a
couple problems there the first is
most of the countries around the world
think the way i do what i just said
all right you took if you went around
and asked them they all would say the
same thing but they just won't say it
publicly
because all these countries china has
enormous leverage on them and
economically they need china
economically they're smaller economies
and so forth
so it takes a very forceful position on
the part of the united states
for other countries to be willing to
step forward there are exceptions
australia as being one of them and a few
others
but generally speaking look at europe
it's not that these countries agree with
china
it's that they don't want to speak out
because they don't want to get hit with
their own sanctions they don't want to
get hit economically
but they need forceful american
leadership in order to make these things
happen
i don't think you've seen forceful
american leadership on anything from the
biden administration so far much less
this all remember let alone iran what
they're trying to do begging to get back
into a deal with one of the worst
countries ever conceived not the people
but the government
senator i remember what congress did
against iran with sanctions
that pushed the president to take action
you got this could do that again
i sense that if you made the effort and
i think you will you'll get a lot of
democrats on board with this
well we're hoping to here's the bottom
line all we're asking for is that china
open up and allow a full
investigation because this is not just
about punishing china what happened in
the past okay
this is about preventing it from
happening again for all we know
at this very moment the next great
pandemic is being developed inside of a
chinese laboratory and they're using
they're doing it because they want to
develop a vaccine or a cure
but the thing infects somebody that
works in that lab and they take it out
and now the whole world gets hit
i get i remind everybody coronavirus is
bad there are worse things out there
that could leak out if that's the way
this happened
we need to know the world needs to know
because this is not a china issue
this is a global issue and if they
didn't lie to us we would have known
what was going to hit us we would had a
test ready for it but they did
british scientists peter dozick has been
removed from the covet commission
looking at the origins of the pandemic
this guy is an embarrassment you watch
him on 60 minutes lie through his teeth
saying i believe the chinese even though
i didn't see anything directly
every time he talks there's some type of
agenda there and he's got direct links
to the wuan lab
now he admits there might have been bats
there when he said there were no
bats there this is long overdue yeah
sometimes these guys like to play god
right and so when they what they don't
want they want to do their research
because they know what's good for
humanity they convince themselves of the
exalted position that they're from and
in and so what happens is now they're
fearful oh my gosh
we don't want this thing linked back to
the kind of research we do so let's do
everything possible to sort of
steer people away from it and cover it
up and that's what this guy did he
rallied a bunch of scientists
who didn't disclose their conflicts
right and the lancet had to come back
later and force many of these people to
disclose their conflicts including him
all right uh one other thing you're
working on you're asking the president
united states for a waiver
so that uh a football star at the navy
school the academy uh navy star cameron
kinley
can play for the bucks he needs a waiver
what are the chances but and by the way
this guy's going to join us uh
in about uh 20 minutes or so needs a
waiver just to delay the military
service right exactly
so you know any inclination that joe
biden will sign
that i don't know yet the white house
has been non-committal so we don't know
yet but here's the bottom line people
got to do it last year
yeah right there are people playing in
the nfl malcolm perry that was came out
of navy plays for the miami dolphins
so last year they were allowed so this
sounds arbitrary where like last year's
club if you graduated last year they're
going to let you do it if you graduate
this year you're not
he's not saying he's not going to do his
service he will i also think this is
really good for the service academies
there's a lot of young men and women who
hope that they might have a career in
athletics
who say look in the off chance that i
get drafted or i get a chance to play
professional sports
the reason why i want to go to the
academy is i have to forfeit that right
now four years ahead of time
so i think that allowing this man young
man to play isn't just fair
because he's going to do his service
he's going to live up to his commitment
but
it's not just fair it's good for the
academies it's going to make it easier
for me and my colleagues here to find
young men and women to step forward
and be willing to be nominated and go to
the service academies oh it would be so
wonderful if joe biden would give him
that opportunity
he might not get an opportunity like
this again and he's going to serve
he's going to join us later on in the
show all right thanks for doing that for
him that's very nice of you
thanks senator thank you thank you